[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Oh
Oh
I
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
you said something so beautiful you said
is so vast is like you're in a small
area has to go pension retired yes your
advice to retire yes you know what the
best fight because now he's the best
he's on the top this is coming from from
the world champion in Bosnia actually
who is at the one in the top they
actually retired himself yes yes huh
and I was twenty I
[Music]
in petition you know what the best part
for me was is when it was over and he
made pledge no sugar he put his head
down and he think the crater alone and
he said in hum didn't wash this is to
meet us the sweetest part the best the
best thing because the lot of people
[Music]
this fight and a lot of people looked at
the center and she's interview after the
fight at the pinnacle you have so many
people watching and now they want to
know like what is best investments for
Islam people start to see like him going
and exhibiting good good manners and
then like k1 boxing it's forbidden in
Islam in competition for competition and
but you can do it a lot of Duty for
because a lot of people look at you when
you said the one sentence
[Music]
it's huge
you know Muhammad Ali he used to come to
see was in Chicago Muhammad Ali the
Muslim American Hero
he used to come to our Dallas center to
my teacher used to tell me that he used
to come and he used to get pamphlets you
know pamphlets and then because he goes
out of there
so the pamphlets would say who is Jesus
in Islam what did you say and he would
sign these and give to the pieces I like
what you said because one sentence you
say people are listening and now of the
people yeah I think 1 billion people who
could this fight in Abu Dhabi and and he
said Allah alhamdulillah so that's what
I tell people who are ok now they don't
want they they're in this they're not
going to get them out use the platform
that the Creator Allah gave you use it
for good
[Music]
lot of respect between
[Music]
[Music]
they were like hospitality person said
talking about going to enemy so when he
went there I'm treating me like an enemy
which treated me like family
yeah we want the best for everybody
Primo's a lot rational section
yes I suppose not everybody
well it just gave me a sure semi
location I'll be man is time man send
the location we gotta get you on sir
look another sign look at that he just
spit me this as a gift
thank you for the suckle I thank you so
much I mean send me location let's do it
on the Dean show me